各位你記得
那阻力要騙你就是
他把股票賣掉了
他就是會讓你想要去買
他假如要去買股票了
就會讓你想賣股票
其實你盤中呢
你可以跟你的情緒為敵
跟情緒為敵
你想買的時候可能就是想賣的時候
太難了
各位觀眾朋友大家好
歡迎收看雅筑黑客室
我是雅筑
一天能賺進400萬
真的不是夢嗎
如果你也想要在一兩天內
賺盡大把財富
無論是多頭或是空頭市場都可以操作
今天這集你絕對不能錯過
今天我們特別邀請到的是
全台灣前三大的當充客
要來教你要怎麼當充
馬上邀請到今天的來賓是全村小哥
嗨
小哥請問當充到底有什麼秘訣
你覺得在標的選擇上有什麼樣的條件
首先我們來看這個
第一个成交量要大
流动性要好
这肯定啊
那日均量3000
3,000以上我觉得很基本的
那基本上
3万
这个3万5万10万都很好
我像我最近还蛮常冲那个00981
哦最近的量好大哦
所以它的量很大
那第二个呢
波动幅度要大
00981它的波动幅度还算
没有很大
但是只要大行情的话
由于它的量体太大
所以它还蛮好做的
那波動幅度大的股票
通常都是前一天呢
有大漲的股票
那前一天大漲股票可能就漲停
舉例來說
他假如前一天漲停是沒有量的漲停
那大概率今天可能還蠻強的
那假如前一天漲停是爆大量的漲停
或者是爆大量的長紅
那一種股票呢
其實他隔天他的波動會很大
因為呢他會有很多隔日充要出貨
然後呢隔日充出貨前呢
他又會這個
又使人家進去買
它會讓你覺得哇這張股票量滾量好像要拉
而事實上是他們要出貨
因為波動幅度要大
然後又加上你量要大
一定是當下的熱門題材嘛
所以像你自己在當中
你會選擇熱門題材去衝嗎
一定的
通常
例如說短空的股票
它可能就是昨天的搶勢股
那昨天的搶勢股呢
有些搶勢股呢
它大概只能搶一天
那我怎麼知道它會搶幾天
基本上你只要看它的月線抖不抖
月線假如很抖的話
月線很抖往上
然後股價沿著
富林上通道的話
那這種是很強的
那這種就不知道它會搶幾天
那它假如是
富林通道走平或者是往下
那月線往下
然後它這種大常用的漲平
那通常都是搶一兩天
好那可是很多人也會擔心說
因為比如說像有些投資小白好了
他沒有當沖過
那你覺得以你的角度來說
當沖到底有什麼
就是你必須要先知道的事情
可以跟小白分析一下
好那我們先講一個最基本的
限股當沖資格
它開後要滿三個月
對
那今年成交10筆以上
這個看起來都蠻簡單的
然後再簽署風險的預告書
那資券當沖的資格
這門檻比較高
那我強烈建議你
兩個一定都要開起來
欸為什麼
因為有可能你做限股當沖
但是你有可能突然沒沖掉
例如說你做先賣
然後被鎖長點
然後這個找不到
因為你沒有開那個資券戶
那就勢必得去借券
那這種有時候
再借券費、手續費
再加上隔天的跳崩
有時候都賠很大
所以呢
有時候都建議你
假如有資券
至少可以改個券
那資源當中資格呢
門檻比較高啦
就今年成交金額達25萬
還要開信用交易帳戶
那第三個呢
是交易成本
那交易成本
這個手續費是1.125
然後呢
這個當你量大的話
就可以移價
量大就是你假如可以做到
量大就是這種啦
其實你剛講我前三面
我沒那麼大
但是台面上可能有啦
就是有出來上課的可能有
但實際上比我大的人很多啦
比我大的人很多
那這個
你假如是上億以上
我覺得大概手續倍大概就可以談
都可以談的
都可以談一下
因為你的量也蠻大的
對券商貢獻蠻多
對國家貢獻也很多
這種貢獻很多的
通常可以談一下
那這個有機會談到二三成
假如是一億以上的話
那當沖證交稅是千分之1.5
那跟一般的證交稅千分之三不一樣
對
現股當沖呢
他是有打折的
我們現在大家有了這個資格囉
那大家有些想說
那當沖到底有什麼樣的優缺點
因為很多人都想說當沖
大家最直覺啦
投資小白想到的最直覺的優點就是
可以無本當沖嗎
我不用有那麼多錢嗎
我還是可以賺錢
那如果說以你的角度來看
當沖的話
有什麼樣的可以跟大家分享嗎
當沖的優點就是
第一個沒有隔夜的風險
可是我就是怕沖不掉
其實沖不掉都是不甘心停損才會沖不掉
例如說放空遇到漲停
做多遇到疊停
通常我們看到很多違約交割的
我們都會去看它的分點跟它的點位
大部分都捨不得停損
那種捨不得停損一次違約交割
它一輩子大概就掛了
所以這個是最嚴重的
各位記得一定不要去觸犯這個微交的條款
是
那優點是沒有隔壁風險
然後沒有隔壁風險就是你不用怕
今天晚上這個川普又對伊朗幹了什麼事
對
第二個呢
資金效率高
像當初我們會來回做很多
像有時候
有時候我一天衝就是衝幾億到這個十幾億
或幾十億
你看大戶呵呵呵呵那這個就資金效率會很高我們其實都是找事件来冲怎么说其实我们冲都会知道一些
例如说我们通常量最大的时候
是在做结算那一天
做结算那一天那量都超大
通常有可能会把这个户头的额度
把它冲到没了
因为结算它就很好做
它就是我这边用现货冲
我那边用期货避险
这个就可以来做套利了
第三个 证交税减半
第四个 快速累积经验
但是很多人做当冲
都是平感觉啦
其实我们都讲了 平感觉做当冲
用运气赚钱 用实力输回去
就是你怎么来的就怎么吐回去
因为这个平感觉做当冲
我没看过赢钱的
缺点的交易成本轻时获利
因为交易成本非常非常重
非常高
那个手续杯跟交易税其实蛮可玩的
我一個月的交易稅都是上百萬
哇
一年都是上千萬
所以
各位有領到那個
土巴一萬
從這裡來的
我也貢獻了一點功勞
因為那個
因為那個超額稅收嘛
就是我們的證交稅
第二個這個
沒辦法龍券
只能付昂貴的券就行了
那第三呢
壓力跟情緒負擔滿大的
所以這個有個盯盤
真的要盯著
所以我覺得做當充
我看當充的很多
衝一衝
那個都會變胖
欸 真的喔
為什麼
因為當衝
順利就順利嘛
不順利你的身體就覺得
你好像遇到了危險嘛
身體遇到危險呢
他就基本上就幫你囤積一點能量了
他就怕你要
要在地盤中
第四個微小個風險啊
這個是我覺得最嚴重的
所以呢
一定要控管好風險
是那我還有一個小問題喔
因為像我自己啊
以我自己的舉例來講好了啦
就是我當衝呢
其實我有時候會習慣在盤前先掛單
你自己會做這件事情嗎?
也會掛啊
也會掛嗎?
但盤前這些主力都蠻騙的啦
常常最後一秒抽單耶
對 我們都說這轉線主力
10個90個騙人
對啊 都在抽單耶
對啊 他們都會一直亂抽
他們現在不只盤前抽
你現在五分鐘
五分鐘四抽額他們也在玩
哦
對 五分鐘四抽額
他就最後兩秒才抽單
所以說這個最後兩秒前
抽360
然後一抽單變340
那這些呢我們盤中的我們都會從那個
正價差比跟逆價差比看得到
盤錢我可以掛今天當沖的這個價格好
那你價格你是怎麼去決定要掛多少錢
盡量這個盤錢掛價格都是
你掛賣就掛高一點
你掛買就掛低一點
我就會少到
可是那如果說我掛買要掛低一點
我就怕買不到啊
你盤錢不用那麼害怕買不到
除非說這檔股票真的很強
舉例來講喔
例如說
期貨開了七八趴
看起來也真的很強
那現貨的單子呢
它的試抽的張數是
微買張數越來越多越來越多
只要試抽微買張數越來越多
它有可能是真的
喔
那假如是試抽的微買張數呢
在59分之後呢
開始這個急劇的減少
那很有可能就假的
那如果說好
我今天看到一檔股票
它試抽漲停了
我今天要怎麼做
假如試桌漲停的話
我們看期貨有沒有漲停
或期貨有沒有大漲
那假如期貨連大漲也沒有
那大概率這個試桌漲停呢
很有可能是隔日沖去弄的
因為隔日沖他都習慣
上去就下來
對 試桌先給你戳漲停
讓一些人去追嘛
前幾天還有一個人因為這樣子被抓
就是因為他試桌漲停
老是騙人家去買
那所以呢這個
試桌漲停開板沒漲停的
那通常今天都會有潛在的賣壓
假如有隔衝的話那就很肯定他一定會買
一開盤就直接被倒貨了
對
那假如試戳跌停開盤沒有跌停
那有可能這個試戳跌停是故意要吃貨
哦
各位你記得
那主力要騙你就是
他把股票賣掉了
他就是不會讓你想要去買
他假如要去買股票了
就會讓你想賣股票
其實你盤中呢
你可以跟你的情緒為敵
跟情緒為敵
你想買的時候可能就是想賣的時候
太難了
就是一般人而已啊
因為每個人都說
如果当中大部分都赔钱
嗯大部分赔钱对啊
因为你大部分都是靠情绪下单
嗯
你的情绪大部分都做反
那你刚刚有提到一个很重要的关键
就是要看正逆价差比
我们要怎么看
正逆价差比的指的是那个期货跟现货
嗯
那当盘前正价差比大
例如说这个
呃期货比较贵
嗯
主力压股票买期货
那这通常比较偏多
通常啦
它没有一定
那逆价差比大就是主力拉股票
然后它在空期货
那通常比較偏空
他主要就是要去見他的部位
好那我盤前我都觀察好這些阻力在做什麼事情了
那我盤中呢
先看你是日內破的Tick流
那通常我都會選擇日內破比較好做
那除非我當天很閒我再做Tick流
或者是我量很大我就每個Tick都掛待
然後就來回刷
這個要本金夠大啦
就是你的量做大一點你可以來回刷
尤其是那種一兩百塊的
來回收到還不錯
哦
那通常我們建議日內波比較好
比較好做
那日內波就是你要去看一下說
你今天到底要做多還做空
嗯
做到做空
可是像做多做空
以你自己的經驗來講
哪一個會比較容易賺錢
就是短空比較容易賺錢
台股的上漲
大部分取決於票控
就是他是給
劉昌的人一個紅利債
這個我們有做過大數據統計啊
說當中呢
大部分做先買再賣的
大部分赔钱做先卖再买的大部分赚钱那所以为什么大家做当中都赔钱因为大部分都做错事实上是你要留波段多单
例如说台子群留多单
台积电你留多单
那这都要过夜
过夜会有过夜的红利
然后
波多单是过夜去赚波段
然后空单是当天做短空
因为台股是一个潜碟市场
它會有很多這個隔日蔥
隔日蔥只會買了它今天會到貨
對
那這個你可以運用這些隔日蔥到貨的這個
籌碼狀況來做短空
是可是因為你知道現在我們其實想到現在的盤
整天漲一千點跌一千點都不意外
其實現在以我自己角度來講
我覺得現在的當沖反而是比較難做一點點的
如果是你怎麼看這件事情
其實我們覺得最近蠻好做的
因為第一個波動大
波动大就好
可是它有时候太大了你知道吗
我还怕它没波动
其实有波动都是好事
是喔
那太大的话
我们的做法是这样
接下来说
我们是顺大事逆小事
什么叫顺大事呢
就是今天我觉得它是黑K
我就先卖再卖
我觉得它是黑K的话
我觉得它是红K
我就先卖再卖
对
这叫顺大事
但盤中的会逆小事
逆小事就说因为盤中它都是一个
波动的过程
那波动过程呢我们在
转弯的地方
会去动作
这个我常会贴我的对账单
这个是我昨天的对账单
那你可以看到我昨天我就是
打定主意先卖再买
哦对耶
我打定主意先卖再买嘛
然后呢
这个每次有在转折的地方
转折的地方就是他杀下去有个
转弯的地方我都会去买
拉上來呢
快要找完的地方
我又去空
所以你看我那邊中間
在11點多的時候
有一個買288
然後抬上去之後呢
291 295.5 297
我又再空回去
然後疊下我再買回去
那我們這個單字就是
你看它密密麻麻的
那事實上我們是順大勢
我覺得它今天應該是黑K
它也真的是黑K
只要是符合我的想法的
那其實我就會來回刷
那來回刷的好處就是
我可以把我的這個買賣的累積的章數變多
嗯
那來回刷我的
我可能我買賣的均價的價格差距呢
會變小
但是呢
實際上賺的總值是變大
漲到買盤接近的時候會去空
那跌到賣盤接近的時候會去買
是
可是因為剛剛我們前面其實聊到很重要的一件事情
當充不要凹單
對
為什麼
平常做當充你會遇到四種狀況
这种状况就是大赚大赔小赚小赔
对啊
那
大赚当然是最好
小赚也不错
小赔是你最好的朋友
有机会小赔你就小赔
那有机会小赔是这样子
就举例来说假设我放空
我空在90块
被嘎到93
然后跌下来变92
这时候93已经算有点大赔了
跌到92呢
变有点小赔了
你就会出了吗
這時候我會選擇
這個賣盤捷徑這個點我會選擇回股
為什麼
因為我剛剛賠更慘了
所以有個回檔
因為剛剛一個買盤捷徑
我當然不想在那邊停損
但是下來有個賣盤捷徑
即便它沒到我的成本
我也是會停損
那我這個停損的點
它就是個小賠的點
好那可是像停損
是有一個%數可以去計算嗎
你大概多少你會停損
我大部分的抓停損
我是刷買賣盤的解禁點
嗯
那當沖呢
最大的停損大概5%
我大概就會很想停損
5%感覺已經蠻大
但是你停損你也不能設太小
你設太小你一直在停損
那也賺不到錢了
對啊我覺得
我覺得你不如好好研究籌碼
然後呢
這個停損%數設大一點
但是張數不要太大
當你張數大的時候
都是有賺錢的時候
我們都是有賺錢
那張數就可以來回刷
對
那假如沒賺錢呢
我的账数就不会大
好那我们刚刚看完盘前啊
盘中该做的功课
那盘后呢
我们是不是要复盘
怎么复盘
你就去看那个分点的筹码状况
哦
我们要了解一下
今天谁害你赔钱的
嗯
是哪些分点
把它买上去的
哦
你可以去研究这些
或者是哪些分点在停损
嗯
假如做多你遇到分点停损
那事实上
它有可能让你今天赔钱
但是
明天可能就有机会了
明天就有机会赚钱
因为
只要它停损光了
那股票就容易上了
是
我們都常講
這個停損大戶是來發紅包的
你不要跟他一起停損喔
你反而是要在
在他停損完的時候呢
強力的做多
嗯
好那是因為我其實也常常聽到股民在哀嚎
就是說就像剛才我們講的嘛
我明明就是看到主力在大買啊
但是我為什麼一買他他就跌了呢
那小哥你能幫我們破除說
比如說散戶在看籌碼的時候
最常犯的一些盲點會是什麼
是他的點位不好
可是那我怎麼知道我進去的點位好不好
舉例來講喔
嗯
都長四根了
第五根你還要追
好啦不會
對啊有的人就這樣子啊
那例如說都漲到明天要被關了
你今天還要買
所以他就有點FOMO
他說長那麼多
被關也很強啦
那其實我們據統計
大部分被關的第一天
平均來講比較弱啦
當然你也會遇到很強的
但是平均來講比較弱
就代表說你做這個策略是
平均來講大概會輸錢
好可是很多人會想說
好那明天是出關的第一天
通常會往上漲吧
出关第一天有分5分钟跟20分5分钟的出关就我们的统计5分钟出关通常比较弱为什么因为其实5分钟大家都还可以买还可以接手对对对对对结巴克5分钟的出关就我们的统计5分钟的出关通常比较弱为什么因为其实5分钟大家都还可以买还可以接受对啊
联发科5分钟其实也还好
因为你总不会买到29张联发科吧
联发科他只是规定你不能买超过29张而已
一般的买个一张两张就很多
那这个不过他还是变弱了
那这5分钟的其实他假如有机会跌下来
很多人都会进场
那很多人都會想說出關那天會比較強
所以大家都選出關那天賣
所以當天可能會開高走低的機率比較大
那如果20分鐘盤出關呢
20分鐘盤出關呢
據我們統計的上漲比較多
因為20分鐘盤是一般人都不能買
買不到了 對
你必須要入金才能買
對
所以20分鐘不大一樣
是那所以等我們總結來看
你覺得散戶最常犯的錯誤會是什麼
就點位啦
點位有可能最高
然後有可能用情緒
哦
例如說
你看到主力
看到那單子一直攻一直攻
他就想進去啊
對 我就看到大戶就一直在買啊
對啊 你就想進去嘛
事實上
那個點喔
我們用軟體看到
我們看到連次量爆量
即拉遇到連次量爆量
這時候是容易轉折的
所以我們是用數據來判斷他會要轉折
賞或是用情緒呢
來買股票
嗯
所以呢 我常常
常常我今天做的股票大賺錢
我回去看分點
哇國泰都難用大賠
因為又是他買的
他都會買在那個情緒的高點
坎在恐慌的低點
那反而這種
他賣下來
產物看到一直賣很恐慌
然後急殺一直賣恐慌
然後出大量
看到他出量了又更害怕又去賣
這點常都是轉折點
所以展望都是用那個情緒來下單
那如果說要請你給現在剛進場想學
就是你剛說籌碼分析的小白
一個很重要的建議
你覺得會最重要的是什麼
就是每天要研究籌碼
喔
做當中一定要看籌碼啦
因為基本面其實變化沒有太大
是
但是籌碼變化會很大
那你要懂得節奏
節奏是這樣子的
就有些股票就紅黑紅黑紅黑
它主力就一買一賣一買一賣
然後它主力一買一賣
他的K棒就一紅一黑一紅一黑
嗯
你都看了十次一紅一黑了
下次紅的隔天你又想做多
我就不曉得你在想什麼
好那如果他紅紅紅呢
這種你會再做多嗎
不會
為什麼
因為你怎麼知道他這次還會紅
他前面就是好都演著五日線紅上去啊
好紅紅紅紅
他通常會遇到有一天是長黑
對
可是你不知道那一天
對啊你到那一天怎麼辦
而且這種紅紅紅
有的已經快要被關了
但有時候你一進場
套勞不賣
其實很多人做當衝是這樣
套勞不賣嘛
原本是做當衝的
然後這個賠錢變存股
然後存股完了又遇到儲置
又被關又往下殺
那這個是最慘的就是
他也不去懂股票的節奏
然後他就一直靠情緒下單
靠情緒下單
然後他也不去管
怎麼處置這種事情
也不管事件
那其實這個都很危險
好 最後一點時間
小柯今天其實也準備了
他今天的對賬單要跟大家分享
快來跟大家再分享一下
這個我的
這是我右邊是我的閃電俠嵐
這是永風的大號系統
然後左邊是我平常在看的
像我們這邊有會看連次量
我覺得連次量非常重要
連次量你假如兩個都亮燈
然後遇到極拉的話
像你看到那個技嘉
這個十次203兩個都亮燈
盤中角看到比這個數字更高
遇到極拉
那他有格式充的話
通常都容易轉折
更容易往下
那假如是連次量綠色的
那極殺他容易反彈
所以會用連次量來看
然後呢這邊還有一個均量比
均量比看的是
他今天這場股票他的量
跟平常的量
看起來是爆多少
像今天我做底元
我今天做的量蠻大的
我做到200多張
其實整場做完是做了300多張
那做完300多张呢
这个我都是靠连次量去做
连次量呢
其实就是你看多方的攻击啦
你可以这样想
连次量只要是红灯
就是多方获胜一次
一次两次三次四次五次
那你知道这个股票越涨越高
多方不可能一直都胜利
对
那总有会到一个地方呢
它的买气衰竭
那买气衰竭呢
它的红色的连次量就会变成绿色
那這個點就容易是轉折點
哦
那一樣
我們是去抓盤中的這個
買賣盤捷徑的這個衰竭
所以呢
買盤捷徑我們是準備空
所以有句話叫做空在爆量漲不動
你發現他一直出量了
一直一直漲不上去差不多了
快跌了
哦
那賣盤捷徑呢準備做得多
買在爆量跌不動
他一直殺
你看他量一直出來
一直殺
下不去了
但也要談
哦
是這個意思啦
當你會抓轉折
你才能來做當沖
你不是沒事看到就買
然後想到就賣
那這種大概率都是賠錢
好今天非常謝謝小哥
來到雅豬惠客室
跟大家分享他的當沖心法
我相信大家應該收益良多吧
大家如果有什麼問題想問的話
歡迎在底下留言
我們都會看喔
那我是雅豬
我們就下次見囉
掰掰
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive